use the broadcaster Danny Baker has been
fired from the BBC over a tweet he sent
about the new son of the duke and
duchess of sussex the broadcaster
deleted the tweet and apologized for
what he called stupid unthinking gag pic
let's turn to our reporter who's
covering this story he'll announce live
Helen and welcome to you what's the
statement from Danny Baker and indeed
the BBC yeah things moving really
quickly this morning Danny Baker is in
trouble over a tweet he sent yesterday
regarding the birth of the new son of
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex Archie
Harrison I'm in that tweet there was a
historical picture a black-and-white
picture of a very well-to-do looking
couple holding the hand of a small
chimpanzee dressed in a suit and a hat a
people reacted really with outrage
saying this was a racist tweet and that
the connotations were really shocking um
I spoke to Danny Baker this morning we
knocked on his door
and he didn't want to speak on on camera
but we did have quite a long
conversation and in that he really quite
shocked almost upset I think herb would
describe it as and he kept repeating
Occam's razor to me that that theory
that the simplest solution is often
easier and more obvious than that more
complicated one his argument was that he
just didn't realize and he said to me
you know how could anybody think that
it's acceptable how could any right
minded person a tweeter picture a
chimpanzee when talking about a small
child and it then transpired just a few
minutes later that the BBC had fired him
for that tweet I spoke to him a second
time before that news was announced and
and he really looked quite upset I said
are you surprised he said no I fought
this on myself he I also said he do you
feel in any way let down by your former
employer and he said no I don't i just
feel let down that people didn't believe
I didn't mean this
he has subsequently tweeted an apology
which I'll just reach you now he said
would have used the same stupid picture
for any royal birth or Boris Johnson kid
or even one of my own
it's a funny image a funny image
though not of course in that context
enormous mistake for sure for a desk
anyway here's to your Archie Sorry mate
so Danny Baker are clearly apologetic
deeply regretting what he did but
insisting he just didn't realized the
racist connotations of that tweet